the men's college basketball
championship that was last night oh come
on yeah
Virginia beat Texas Tech in overtime
you're either happy about that or you've
been partying recently in Mexico anyway
that was a it was exciting did you did
you watch the big game Andy nope all
right well you filled out a bracket
right
what's a bracket okay well that's the
thing where you guess who's gonna win
all the games in the NCAA tournament
what - NC double-a this is crazy Andy
you really don't know anything about
sports
not at all Conan then you know what time
it is
I sure do that's right it's time for
Andy Richter's sports blast
[Applause]
welcome to sport class let's bless some
sports sports we've got a ton of sports
blasts starting with this sport score
three to nothing that means just time to
head over to the wall of basketballs
wall of basketballs all right hit me
that means it's time to check in with
the green screen correspondent trade
triple third the third trade
hey Andy hey Trey what cool green
screens have you got for us tonight well
right now it looks like I'm standing on
a football field
now on the basketball court whoa sports
a lot of beach sports not without our
space back to you Andy Wow now let's go
to correspondent Conan O'Brien with a
list of Super Bowls yeah thanks Andy
i XYZ XXVII back to you Andy
oh thanks Conan now let's check back in
with green screen correspondent trade
triple third the third thanks Andy
penguins back to you Andy wow you've got
you got up green streams Bessie you
Conan thanks Andy back to you let's wrap
it up with a sports clip of the week
sports clip of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
wow you've got a love sports well that's
our show tune in next week next time for
another edition - Andy Richter Sports
blast
[Applause]
sports